[Music]
hello my name is matt you're watching
codetech tutorials
three things you can do to make your
tech job much more
manageable for yourself for your
mentality for your
ability to stick with it and improve
from it and
basically all the good things to to make
the best out of your tech job there's
got to be a really good way of wording
this that i'm missing yeah so three
tech job things that you should know now
these are things that i have
personally experienced it's been quite a
ride and these are the things i've
learned that i think are really
important
and that if you're new to all this you
can really take a lot from these
and i think do well
all right well i think the number one
thing here is
you need to separate your work and
personal life not completely we'll get
to that but
in the sense of your devices now a lot
of us tech people are rather creative
and like other things we're not only
doing
tech so it's really important to have
separate
notes and devices and this is there's
legal reasons why too
so i'll try to be brief but i want to
cover the big thing all right so
first of all just first of all there's
like several parts to this
if you show up with stuff ready to go
for work
that looks really good on you and it
makes a world of difference for you
picking up the job
i know um without getting into super
specific details every job
that i've ever started i learned to
bring a fresh
notebook a notebook with nothing else in
it that is specifically
for this job and you just you just jot
down
anything that you might forget our
brains are not very good at remembering
things long term
unless we repeat it and repeat it so
when you're getting all this new
information and new to the job
you're gonna have a lot of stuff thrown
at you that you're gonna you just know
you're gonna have to ask again
but if you write it down then you don't
have to go bother anyone again
you learn it once and everybody loves
you when you do that because they don't
want to be bothered with the same
questions over and over
trust me it gets frustrating to to
for some guy to hear how do i reset my
password again like 20 times a day i
guess it gets real annoying
that's just an example but you want to
do that for generally everything
maybe you have a special thing you need
to know about a procedure that's
a strange order that you're never going
to remember until you do it a few times
write it down the first time that's it
and whoever's
teaching you it will appreciate that
you're saying hold on slow down let me
make sure i get these steps right
because they know that they can rely on
you to get it done when the time comes
and
you're not going to come calling them at
3am or whatever being like i need to do
this and i don't know how
because you can just flip open your book
find the steps and be like yeah there we
go
don't need to call jim again he's tired
of being bothered anyway
and there's more to this too there's
another reason you should separate your
stuff
so say say you have your own personal
laptop or a computer
and you decide i want to use it for work
but then
you maybe in your own time make
something on your computer like a piece
of art
a piece of code a program a script it
could be anything
but if you did it on your computer
during
workplace owns it you got you got that
yeah everything you do at work your
workplace owns
typically there might be some exceptions
but that's pretty standard
so you should be using a separate device
for work
at work and only do work stuff there if
you're taking an hour break or two hour
break and you want to work on your own
stuff
switch to your own laptop and do it on
your own time on your own laptop
that's pretty big because there there
have been many
lawsuits about this sort of thing about
hey you created it on company time
thus it's the companies too bad and
there are also
great you know positive stories of this
about people who have done things on
their own time while still working and
not gotten in any trouble because
hey they did it on their own time on
their own device had nothing to do with
all their work stuff
and maybe they were able to make a great
side hustle or
get it who knows it's it's they have the
legal rights to it is the point
but if you do it on your work stuff
during work time especially
and you know there's always the argument
to be made if you did it on your work
device
or the device using for work and the one
of the time stamps on it somewhere
during your work time
you could get an illegal battle there
even if you tried to do a legit on your
own time
on the computer you know and it's it's
it's going to get tricky so just
completely separate those devices
alright let's move on to the second
thing
[Music]
now this one's this like i said these
are going from my own experience so i
just this one feels weird to say but
it's find your crew
and what that means is find people at
work that you actually
like and that you get along with and uh
this is actually
i guess for some people it's difficult
for some people it's easy it depends on
how extroverted you are depends how open
you are
and and that sort of thing so um
yeah it really just makes a big
difference like when you think about it
if you wake up in the morning and you
know you have to work today
you have these thoughts about what
work's going to be like it might be
subconscious you might actually be
thinking through it
and if you know that everybody's mean
and you don't have anyone to talk to
and you might not be very motivated but
if you think about oh
so and so is going to greet me today we
can talk about this thing that we've
been
uh hashing out and or something or maybe
we have lunch plans today you're going
to be
a lot more motivated to come to work if
you're working with people that
feel like people you want to be around
or
your crew so you kind of want to get
that mentality going on
at least a little bit now like i said
this is my own personal experience
i've always loved making friends at work
and it's it's really made a difference
for me
so i know some people are going to be
like no i go to work and i don't talk to
anybody i just do the work and leave
that's fine i guess
but it's kind of it's just really hard
for people to understand you
and work with you basically because if
you're hard to understand you're hard to
work with
and it just you gotta have some kind of
connection and uh you know that's just
been my personal experience
if you have a lot of trouble with this
and want to get better at it there are
great
ways to learn there's you can just look
at youtube and go to
charisma on command check out their
channel they've got all kinds of stuff
about
uh i don't know just kind of improving
your charisma and learning to talk to
people and deal with situations a little
better so it's a great online resource
you can do privately without
you know having to talk to anybody about
it so that's a really
really great one and also there's
toastmasters most
cities and campuses and stuff will have
a toastmasters organization
and what that is is basically an
organization that's all about
improving your ability to speak in front
of
people and crowds and and give speeches
when necessary
it's something i joined at one point
because i just wanted to get a little
more comfortable in front of crowds
and it's definitely made a pretty big
difference for me everyone there is uh
well they have a code
so everyone there is generally rather
positive
but also rather critical they will let
you know what they think
you're doing wrong and you do the same
for them it's just a big collective
group
of people that uh you know just
genuinely want to get better
at their public speaking public
appearance and in all of that it's kind
of a well-rounded thing because you get
some real
personal experience and it could be a
way to to make friends if you're having
trouble with that too
so you know that might not be for
everybody but
i found it to be helpful it was really
stressful at first to have to do it and
then after a while it gets easy
and then you know some big thing happens
in your life where you actually have to
handle a real situation and you're
mentally prepared because you've been
through all this
uh we'll say torture and toastmasters
it's not torture it's
it's stressful if you're not used to
speaking in front of crowds but it gets
easier and that's the point it's like a
um the whole therapy by
exposure thing and i'm not saying that
right but you probably know what i mean
no this is not an advertisement and not
sponsored by toastmasters or anything
although i am looking for sponsors so uh
send me an email
all right and another part of this oh
finding people you like to work with and
is just know your real goals that's
actually really big i think because if
you know your real goals it's kind of
what's gonna
come out naturally and you're gonna
connect with people like that
all right number three this was also
just as important
as the first two and this is where you
guys are going to hear things you're
more used to hearing on youtube
because this one's a little bit negative
but it has a positive spin to it it's
positive overall it just it's something
you need to be prepared to do
because it can make a world of
difference too
and that is quit yeah you heard me right
quit you need to quit
didn't see that one coming did you all
right so why do you need to quit
okay well this you don't actually need
to quit
you need to be prepared to quit because
so this is hard to say in the right way
but it's basically
you don't want to be locked into
something or get in a bad situation and
not have a way out or not have any
backups or be
stuck doing something absolutely
terrible and miserable just
because you have no other options those
are all
being cornered situations that you don't
want to be in at work because there
might come a time
where your skill level has risen above
what you were originally hired for
and the your superiors don't see that
necessarily
so you have to be prepared to say hey i
don't want to do this anymore
i would like that job i can do it and
there you go so you quit the original
position you move up
you move theoretically up but it could
just be to anything you're more happy
doing it doesn't necessarily have to be
up
so you have to be prepared to walk away
and say i don't
particularly enjoy this anymore or no
i can't do that that's gonna destroy my
home life where my wife's gonna divorce
me if i
keep working so many hours or or
something like that you don't want to
let work destroy your life that's really
really important i think a lot of people
get in the trap of letting it happen
in a way not a lot of people i don't
know it's everyone's different
but just don't let it happen if you
notice that your work is getting
incredibly negative and
incredibly just i don't know just like
wearing on you and
it doesn't feel good anymore something
needs to change and you need to be
prepared to quit so you should always
have
you know just future plans and this this
is just basic future planning too
you just don't want to be stuck doing
the same thing forever i've wrote down
some more things about quitting i'll
just read off here
you want to quit elegantly you don't
want to go in and do it the
you know the whole upheaval way we'll
just say
you don't want to do it that way you
want to prepare a nice letter and maybe
as soon as the thought crosses your mind
you might want to draft a letter
and then when the thought crosses your
mind again go look at that letter now
keep this on your personal stuff keep it
completely separate from your work stuff
because you don't want something like
this to be discovered early but if
you're planning on moving up
or moving out prepare a graceful exit
there's so many reasons this is
important and it's another thing that
people
miss a lot because with a graceful exit
you get letters of recommendation
you get begged to come back when another
great position opens up
you get a call all these just positives
happen from it or maybe even none of
that happens
but someone else is inspired by you and
you become
business partners in the future you know
there's there's all kinds of great
reasons to
to maintain your image the best you can
now nobody's perfect
we expect us all to make mistakes
probably made a bunch of mistakes in
this video already
for example but i'm just going to
continue alright there's more all right
this
this is another thing about quitting
check yourself first
you want to make sure it's not something
that's where you're the problem and
works great
you don't want to quit because of of
something you're doing
extremely wrong like i can't think of a
great example here other than
maybe you don't get enough sleep and you
come in super tired
works miserable you're having a hard
time performing you're getting
terrible reviews your boss is starting
to hound you maybe something like that's
happening and the issue isn't work maybe
you really like the work and you really
want to keep it the issue is
you've got some cycle at home that's not
going well
so the lesson here is uh just make sure
it's not you check yourself
before you wreck yourself sort of thing
don't just quit when you don't have
other options
just because uh you don't like it but
you know
also maybe if you can't maintain the
schedule there's something to that you
need a different one you know it's just
a sign
so it's just it's also a thing that just
means
make sure you're actually improving and
looking better every day if you can
all right well the other reasons to quit
and these are more understandable
than the others maybe other than moving
up and stuff um
some ceos and companies are just fooled
really toxic people
and that is not your fault it is
absolutely not your fault that other
people
are crazy you know you it's you didn't
do it
it's it's simply not your fault that
doesn't mean you shouldn't
offer whatever you can if when the
situation comes if someone's
sort of having a breakdown at their desk
and throwing papers and slamming stuff
or whatever
and you're there and you i don't think
you should just sit by idly and blankly
unless you're concerned for your safety
that's a little different
you should say something but also i
might put it in your head that this
might
not be the position for me but that
person is a person they're struggling
with something
maybe maybe your words can help them so
this is something i've had to do on
more than one occasion and i don't say
had to do as like i had no
choice is there something i like to do
if i see someone that seems like they're
struggling as
a human for some reason i usually just
talk to them and it often helps i just
say
it's easy really you just look at them
you just say whatever comes to mind
that's
preferably not offensive um maybe
sometimes it'll come off as offensive
but you just say something like hey
hey man what's bothering you you're
right and maybe they'll just say nothing
and leave
but maybe also they'll just sit down and
sigh and say
i don't know start telling you about
their terrible problem and you can just
listen not along and maybe that'll make
a world of difference to them it's
it's really is really interesting how
how much just a few words can mean to
somebody at the right time
and if you miss it the time's gone and
there this one hits home for me because
i've
okay let's just move on i don't want to
drill that one home anymore i think you
get the point there's a lot of like
therapy type stuff out there on on
youtube and on the internet these days
that i think is really good and a lot
you can learn from it
about this sort of thing so um good luck
try not to be silent in those situations
but know that if it stays toxic and it's
not better it's not getting better you
do have the option to just walk away
and get away from toxic people you it's
it's a matter of controlling your circle
you know you want to be around people
that inspire you that you like
you don't want to be around people that
are treating you terribly so that's
really the limit maybe someone's getting
mad at something that has nothing to do
with you
and it doesn't feel too bad for you but
if they're getting mad at you and
treating you badly because of their
problems that have nothing to do with
you
that's a clear sign that you need to say
something and be prepared to walk away
if they can't adjust and be a civil
human
all right let's see anything else um
the last thing i have is just maintain
honesty if it's not fit for you anymore
you have to be honest about that
situation so i hope you've enjoyed these
tips thanks for watching
special shout out to my patrons you guys
do make this possible
and a few more and
something special will happen with the
channel it's kind of a secret for now
because i'm still figuring it out
but i have some plans thanks again peace
out and good luck
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you